- Hey ya'll we're back with
my friend Garth Brooks!
- [Kelly] Wooo!
(crowd cheering)
(Garth laughing)
- That would've been my sound at your show
when I was a kid.
Ahhhhh.
- He's got --
I'm crazy.
I just saw myself.
(Kelly laughing)
- He's got a new vinyl
box set called Legacy,
and we're breaking down his career,
so far,
with a look at his
albums in the collection.
Next, let's talk about
Garth's second live album,
Triple Live.
These are all songs you
recorded during your world tour?
- [Garth] Yeah, during the comeback tour.
- I saw the show and it was incredible.
- So Garth's wife Trisha Yearwood,
my favorite singer on the planet,
was featured in two songs
on Triple Live, right?
- Yeah, she's the bomb.
- She's so good!
- So you know, when people go,
"Have you been singing together forever?",
Well, yeah.
I mean she has sang on,
we counted it up the other day,
just out of fun.
I think she's sang on over
90 songs in our career,
that's her singing the background vocals
from way back,
first record
to here.
So she's as much the Garth Brooks sound,
or the cooler part of it,
than Garth is,
so she's great.
And all the same players
have played on every record.
- So you record with Trisha all the time,
and I work with my husband.
You know, Brandon.
And, is it hard,
like, to do it on the
road, and work together,
because you're both artists,
like, Brandon and I, my husband and I,
he's my manager and I'm an artist.
We're very different.
Is that hard, because you're both artists?
- Yeah, it's also your best friend,
so you got a lot of good conversations,
and we all want to be like-minded,
we all want to do the right thing,
but how we get there,
you're going to need all the
diversity you can, right?
All the different way of
thinking that you can.
So me and her are always cool
until
it comes to music.
- It just does,
because you know, you look and I go,
"Why do you like that
song? That song sucks."
Wooop!
(Kelly laughing)
- [Garth] And all of a sudden it's like,
"Oh I didn't mean that,
I really didn't mean that."
And it's just how it is,
it's the same way with her.
She'll go, "Why do you use that player."
And you're like, well, you know.
It's just that love --
- [Kelly] You're protective of your --
- Oh that passion.
- [Kelly] Yeah
- For music, it's great.
So we've had some pretty good --
- [Kelly] That's cool though,
because then you'll call each other out.
Brandon and I do that.
We'll call each other out and be like,
"Nah, it wasn't that great.
You could do better."
- [Garth] Yeah I mean,
that's what you do is, you push yourself.
I've never said that.
If he's ever said that to you,
he's a braver man than me.
(crowd laughing)
- He's pretty bold,
that's why I think he's sexy.
(crowd and Garth laughing)
- Something weird about me, I like it.
- [Kelly] So wait,
this can't be right,
I heard about this and I was like,
surely you've done a stadium tour before,
because you're Garth Brooks,
but this is your first stadium tour.
- [Garth] It's my first stadium tour,
Try to remember that we spent
eight years in the 90's.
- Yeah.
- And then the tour was done,
and so went home to raise our babies,
so we started in '14,
so we've actually been
touring for 13 years.
- [Garth] Which is crazy when
you think of it that way,
and so when we came back,
we kind of put a tour
just like the one we just
came off of in the late 90's,
just kind of see where we're at.
So we've never been in stadiums,
but I can tell you this,
I was scared to death stadiums
were going to be cold,
distant, you know?
They are the warmest, coolest,
because, I'm a guy,
I'm the last one that
wants to say size matters.
It does!
- It's fabulous,
and you know, when people sing at you,
Unanswered Prayers.
If you guys have been to a stadium show,
you could vouch for me.
- 17,000 people singing Unanswered Prayers
will tear your heart out.
87,000!
Will tear your heart out
and take you to dinner.
It's fantastic!
So its wonderful!
- Do you get more nervous
in that environment, or no?
- I don't know.
It's...
- Just because it's so big?
I don't really see you
as nervous, actually,
I don't know? Do you get nervous?
- You get nervous, but the truth is,
you stick a guitar in between me and you,
then all of a sudden, I'm home.
- Oh.
- [Garth] So it's very sweet,
these people.
If it's a dive bar of 500,
or if it's a stadium of
however many thousands,
they allow you to suck,
and be okay.
They kind of let you be you, you know?
- [Garth] Scars, flaws and all.
It's like a woman.
The most gorgeous thing a woman can wear
is happiness, right?
- Yeah.
- When they're confident
and happy its like, whoa.
And that's how they make
you feel when you walk out.
That you're happy and you're confident.
It's cool.
- Like, what?
So what I love about you too though,
is you're not, the stadium thing is cool,
but you're also doing a dive bar tour.
- Dive bars are fun.
- Exactly, I love like clubs
oh that's so fun.
- [Garth] Because they're
loud, they're hot --
- [Kelly] And intimate,
and you're right in their face,
and you're all sweating together --
- [Garth] Everybody stinks!
It's awesome.
(crowd laughs)
- [Garth] It's fabulous
because you're sitting there,
and you're sharing the same sweat,
people are, you know,
you can't get to the bar,
because everything is just packed,
so everybody's drinking
from each others' beers.
It's a family thing.
- Not that.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- No.
- It's funny, it's old school.
So it's great,
and these dive bars are just cool.
We're about to do our last one,
but I don't think so.
I think I'm having such
a great freaking time,
I'm going to ask if we --
- I would love to see you in a dive bar!
- Oh let's do it, let's do it.